foreign
this morning in our series the dish we
made a restaurant tour in a former
Master sommelier behind one of Chicago's
hottest restaurants Alpena Singh has
been working in the industry for decades
mostly helping diners pick the perfect
wine but recently she decided to cross
into the kitchen Adriana Diaz caught up
with the self-described curator of all
things delicious and even got some wine
tips you might not expect
at one of Chicago's newest restaurants
is fierce feminine energy
Gaga Frida Kahlo Madonna Elizabeth
Taylor owner Alpena Singh is paying
tribute to women doing things on their
own terms I ordered six bottles so we
can at least try it which is exactly
what the wine expert is doing at her
aptly named Alpena the sommelier's job
is to find the wine that best pairs with
what the chef creates but it was never
our job to go into the kitchen it was
almost considered disrespectful this
didn't go yet right but she's breaking
industry rules creating the dishes
herself with confidence that came from
cooking during quarantine my friends
they were like wow this is really good
you should put this on the menu did it
feel almost like you were not staying in
your lane yeah I had a I I approached a
couple of my friends about like well
who's gonna be the chef I'm like we
don't have a chef and they thought it
was crazy but I think part of me really
changed after the pandemic I think we
saw a lot of Americans that are like you
know what it's either now or never the
California Native moved to Chicago 20
years ago with just a few boxes of books
and clothes and Rose owning multiple
restaurants and hosting the iconic
Chicago restaurant show check please
take us through if you go to Gogi how
should we order are you recognized on
the street uh I I do get recognized I
always get track played
she says her food was inspired of course
buy wine this Pinot Noir and mushrooms
are like peanut butter and jelly they
love each other
dishes like the popular crispy polenta
and mushrooms are comforting yet complex
the mushroom like it pops just kind of
like took over when I had the wine then
there's the delicate tuna Crudo meant to
shape-shift based on the wine pairing
and then go back with some of it's still
in your mouth okay and then go with the
Riesling
it creates a sensation of different
flavors it's like waves of flavors like
the ocean yes where you don't know where
the tuna starts in the line ends it's
sort of a seamless pairing for your
perfect pairing sing shared some
sommelier Secrets I love my guacamole
and chips but it's even better with the
glass of sauvignon blanc because the
sauvignon blanc acts like lime juice
over the guacamole because of the
acidity the acidity so it kind of brings
it alive and then with red wine here's
an easy tip turn the wine on its side if
you can see through it then you can pair
it with things like fish
sing was introduced to the restaurant
world by her parents ethnically Indian
immigrants from the Fiji islands her
father was a dishwasher her mother a
server and it wasn't a path they
envisioned for her I will say that when
I told my mom I wanted to become a
master sommelier she says oh I am so
excited so tell me what part of the body
does the sommelier specialize in what
part of the body yeah she thought it was
a medical specialty I had to bring it to
her that it was drinking
saying a pursuit of spot with the
country's most prestigious and
competitive wine organization so I
thought okay well this exam has a pass
rate of three percent why not me and I
think that sentence right there is what
launched my career why not why not me
all of the greats say why why not me she
passed at just 26 becoming the youngest
and first woman of color to earn the
title Master sommelier I got a lot of
accolades for being young and I'm very
grateful for that but let's face it they
don't hand out 40 over 40 Awards we live
in a society that tends to focus and
celebrate youth particularly with women
and then we kind of disappear from 40
until about 80 and then we become a
National Treasure you know so you know
there's a lot of work to be done between
40 and 80 and in fact some of our best
work she says her best work yet is at
Alpena which is not just her name it's
also her neighborhood how are you how
you feeling Betty you look great your
son came in for dinner your son and your
daughter-in-law
but we see the color on it now she's
adding teacher to her plate with wine
education classes for her staff I see my
dad in all of their faces I see my mom
in all of our servers having a barolo
with a white flesh fish would not go
that was like the one of the main
reasons that I wanted to work here the
wine program and just open up herself
other women come up to me and I said you
know I read about your story I heard
about you and I thought wow maybe I
could do that and this is how we start
changing the face of what it means to
have sort of a you know a stereotypical
just one group doing a profession you
know it's because we all said why not me
and decided to put ourselves in the ring
and that I kid you not it will mean
something to somebody eventually for CBS
mornings Adriana Diaz Chicago
love everything about that woman I love
her confidence I see why she's the
creator of all things delicious yeah now
I don't drink but it seemed like she was
giving good advice about the wine John
turn to the side if it's red and you can
see through it and the parents are
perfect I think she should tell her her
mother the sommelier specializes in the
heart yeah yeah there you go that's what
wine is good for we'll be right back
nicely done I want to go there